hey folks welcome back to the lobby
right here on gamespot.com yeah that's
my name that's my Twitter drop me a hot
social media why don't you it's your
lower third it's my lower third you got
a nice lower third yeah you do what
about my upper third I uh I'll tell you
about that after the show is that right
Brad M from double F hey man how are you
doing
great super exhausted s what's in your
soar rushia whatever the hell this thing
is oh this is a product placement for my
buddy's bar in Portland oh really so
there's whiskey in there uh Bailey's Tap
Room Bailey's Tap Room water I'm not
going to pret's top room yeah it's a
great bar disclosure if you find
yourself in Portland go to it it's it's
amazing I swear you won't be
disappointed is there Bailey's Irish
Cream in
there yo you want some Bailey's Irish
there this is is this a family show or
not this is live that is actually what I
use to prep for live shows though is uh
32 ounces of Bailey's Irish Cream just
keep it in the fridge actually keep it
in the
freezer um and
it's that's what got me through this
making this video we better R run
through this pretty quick then cuz
you're about 20 minutes from being rip
[__] that's true good thing you're not
driving Mary Kish is here no no I can't
actually I requested to not you don't
get Ri [__] on Bailey's you just start
Bing just C you can't you can't handle
it yeah we're going to be doing some
cement mixers later it's going to be
great you never had a cement mixer oh
man we're going to the bar and you're
going to get one have you had one of
those all right you guys are going to
get one it's going to be awesome I don't
know what they combine it with but
essentially they like mix it for you and
you put it in your mouth and it it
curdles in your mouth and then you
swallow it's the worst no one should
ever drink this are you supposed to when
you turn 20 you guys are 21 right oh
this is the worst you yeah you don't
want to look that up just don't do that
one part Bailey I cream one part lime
lime juice yeah yeah yeah it's oh you
don't want that are you supposed to try
and like chug it before it curdles no no
no you're supposed to they kind of they
instruct you to hold it in your mouth
and swish it around and let sort of this
is uh so hey Game Spot yeah so we can
learn some drinking tips I guess Mass
that's a different yeah mass of chalice
hey this is a video game that people
might not know a secret about mass of
chalice what is that secret we just put
it on Early Access this morning this
morning this morning this is I feel like
the timing of the show was amazing it's
almost like we planned it oh no I would
I won't even say that as a
joke I like jokes
but I just feel like I feel like Early
Access is not where I want to be messing
around right now like it's like we put
the game in Early Access we just want to
so so we put it out to our backers like
$50 and up backers we sort of have this
like play the game before anybody else
kind of thing a couple of weeks ago uh
yeah it's been like three weeks it's
been like three weeks so we've getting
like super sweet feedback from uh all
those people that backed it and it's you
know it's been the response has been
really positive like I've been super
super happy with like people are playing
the game and like sharing their you know
a lot of the game is about like emergent
narrative and sort of getting attached
to hero and stuff and people are like
writing their kind of like little you
know their little emergent narratives
they're like typing them up and I'm
reading them and it's the best I have
one printed out on my desk right now
it's the best it makes me super happy I
look at it whenever I read something bad
on the internet I look at one this one I
could print out a bunch jeez jeez damy I
could print out a lot but I print out
the best one I won't tell you whose it
is but I printed out the best one t
shaer uh that would be the best if it
was no it's not Mr sh spoilers it's not
not you did good kid yeah that's it's
just it's just him like giving a thumbs
up uh maybe if if you want to write your
own emergent narrative for Brad's desk
we're giving away a bunch of copies of
massive chalice via social media I
believe if you retweet something that
Gamespot done tweeted um a couple of
minutes ago you should be in on that and
we will announce announce we announce
the win you could also buy the game you
could just buy it 25% off right now yeah
for our like our like launch week in
Early Access maybe let's play it
see if they want it yeah yeah we can do
that yeah but you're not going to do cuz
you can't play in tart any but but yeah
so people anyway people are playing the
game they're playing the game we got the
feedback sweet but a bunch of people
were like hey I missed the kickstarter
how do I play it and I'm like uh we
didn't think about that and so and so we
decided to just like blast the codes out
to everybody who back the game and then
put the game on sale and be like hey
come play it cuz we think it's like in a
finished enough kind of state where come
get some yeah you can play it and have a
good time playing it Mar's playing all
week
Mary have you been having a good time
playing the game you sent me a hilarious
email that was like that was like I was
like oh we can play at the beginning of
the game and this is amazing I can't
believe that just happened this this
coffee table just turned into a do you
want one yeah no you can I can't get and
there's a bunch of there is that's our
secret controllers D are these for
working out yeah we'll do a little bit
of that later do you even lift desks bro
no bro I wanted to just show you what
it's like because um from playing the
last I haven't you know uh I've I've put
in like a few days into this trying to
figure it out here's my auto saves um my
saves so I started with better betterer
and I'm currently on better so I quit
this is great you're 63 years in so uh
awesome and I've gone farther um but
then my Society died so I uh am trying
to start strong because
you know as you'll no doubt explain this
game spans so long that um you know if
you if you make bad decisions in year 20
you're screwed anyway so that is and you
know what that's so true about life like
for everyone out there too many of those
cement mixers in my 20 just be real
careful just be real careful around year
20 this got really real yeah I mean you
can you can really mess things up oh so
the Thematic yeah talk to me about
thematic Okay so uh all of the names of
the heroes the the Bloodlines in the
game came from our backers that backed
at like 100 bucks and up we had this
thing where we like we made this editor
and people could like make their sigil
and choose their colors and and then
submit their names and stuff uh and so
we had to go through them all manually
and some of them are serious and they
sort of feel like hey you want to play a
fantasy game you want to have like you
know be immersed in a fantasy world they
work others don't you know so so we just
like Dave Lang Dave Lang was the reason
why we created this uh this nonthematic
silly silly group I don't know what
you're gonna
find I actually I actually don't play
the game on
that we're having a little technical
problems over here no never a technical
problem it's cuz it's rubbing I know
what it is it's rubbing on his like fat
neck on my upper third it's rubbing on
your fat neck so I started I hit silly
okay yeah that's a pretty big cup would
you say it's no it looks like it is it
looks like the game is having some
technical difficulties is what it looks
like no way we've practice it is in
Early Access we're working on this also
because because we're trying to do a
live thing that's when it breaks it's
cuz you put the Thematic on silly you
should just yeah maybe we shouldn't put
the Thematic silly just alt that for
that thing just just let's start let's
start fresh can we do it do this nobody
look get that camera off
me this is going better than I thought
it would you guys yeah shift tab that
for it yeah it'll work when you play it
at home I swear that's how it
works just turn it off turn it back on
again just yeah get rid of this thing
it's fine it's fine okay we're good it's
going to be fine in a minute yeah um I I
was just playing it um that's why people
that's why people come to the lobby
right so that we can just hang out
that's a hang out show cuz you know you
know the way you always go to hotel
lobbies and you just hang out with
people even if you're not staying at the
hotel oh yeah and all the time all the
things you can do in a hotel lobby we
did we did just patch this uh last night
and it looks like maybe that didn't go
as smoothly as we um what things do you
like to do in lobbies of
hotels drink lemon water uh cement
mixers hang out prostitutes while
they're waiting for their as well do you
want to try it again I think you you
should try it again read
newspapers do you read newspapers free
this one of your favorite things they're
free magazines mag continental breakfast
yeah yeah you want to try silly one more
time I'm simple yeah that looks good I
know what okay sweet we good we good
think it work this time yeah this is the
start well I'll do a clap so we know
where to
edit right just Rel lose all the lobby
stuff we talked about sorry about that
everyone at home but we're working out
it it is a it is like an in progress
kind of video game yeah that's what
Early Access is all about getting all
these fun yeah yeah the great thing
about this you know what I found I hope
I'm not ruining like the story for
anyone should we spoiler people feel
about the show if the guests like talk
over the video game that's cool is that
fine yeah okay we do it every week you
skip um you can totally skip this too
I'll give you the setup in sentence how
do you skip it said Escape yep I've been
clicking like a
fool so so yeah the the setup for the
game is that you as the player you are
this Immortal ruler that has kind of
been summoned is this is this new
information for you this didn't happen
when this amazing you just like I feel
like you just had a revelation we did
just put this in where it just pops up
CU so before I just died a
bunch you you learned by trying slowly
the game the game is tuned pretty
difficult because like we want to make
sure that it's like it's like a pretty
stiff challenge for people that are
familiar with like tactical strategy
games we're going to be putting
difficulty modes and there will
definitely be like an easier one and a
harder one too like I want to have a
really really hard one well pres don't
we all H presumably though your backers
are probably the type of people who want
to play the yeah and you know what they
kind of got they kind of smashed into it
uh right away and were like wow this is
really hard but then as they were
figuring it out they really like now
they're like yeah it's too easy like way
way way too easy and I'm like oh okay I
have a question for you yes um so right
now uh I'm playing uh the game starts
out right in the action so you're
starting out did also did you pick the
silly names you should
gock I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure
that that one character was named Teddy
rumkin what his name roseus Cannon
chorus B this is what this is what our
backers did to me they put me in the
position where we had to like we had to
make a call like do we let people put
teddy rumkin in the game it's like they
paid you $100 so Ro Cannon yeah like we
put that in the game soy hind is really
something it looks like they benefited
you
greatly um and there see also if you hit
um is it right click and you right click
and that will just shortcut also hit you
can click on the flag down there um
which flag yeah the green one that one
right there yep right here and this guy
and then that'll kind of zoom in and you
can actually see the the traits of the
characters too and you can see um the
siblings of the characters if you click
on that I should have forced you to come
down here weeks ago yeah the game's one
thing that I've noticed about the game
it's a lot easier when I'm sitting next
to you explaining it yeah you should
probably we're working on that we're
working on that don't worry about it
what we're learning about um brosus um
the Canon family really helps he he
can't have kids just like yep just like
Dan I can have kids but they just have
smooth faces they don't have any faces
this is the girl we talked about this
off camera what was your term for it
kind of gross out smoo smoothies yeah
they're my little smoothies that's
disgusting and they're often drunk or
hung over these are important traits
later on because you're going to learn
who you want to fight who you want to
teach who you want to make babies uh and
all these traits uh the personality and
and statuses will actually impact where
you want them to go and what you want
them to do so I'm kind of taking note of
these things but he's going to fight
that's his role right now so he just
needs to suck it up and do that um I
think I think if he goes over here I
might get a shot at this guy little far
away yeah so um you'll uh that's not
what I want to do so you'll notice I get
two two action points yeah it's very
very similar to um uh to the new XCOM I
love that game I guess it's like two
years old at this point so I don't know
if I call it the new XCOM anymore but uh
yeah I love that game that was actually
one of the like key things that inspired
this I they did a lot of things right
and I feel like if you're you know no
need to reinvent the wheel when it comes
to like making a strategy game so we
took a lot of cues from them in terms of
like where the camera is the perspective
like all that stuff um their action
point system but a lot of things are
different as well um mainly okay so so
the setup for the game is that you're
this um you're this Immortal ruler and
you've been see jumbalaya on the bou so
every time one of those was that brosus
that guy so every time that guy kills
somebody he'll just say jumble out my
mind this is again this is like the back
yeah this is the battlecry like this is
yeah like every time you kill somebody
what would you say Danny owire what
would you say if you every time you
killed this is for of smoothies right
yeah and then it would go in the Nona
category with me and I've been playing
this I've seen people when they kill
somebody normally they stay they say
stuff like for the you know for the
people exactly and you're like yeah like
there you go
very like you got it but yeah just jum
ey on the bou I guess yeah kill kill
somebody did you have to like then
manually go through all this nonsense
how much have you like development time
was it like four weeks where all you
done spreadsheets and our uh producer on
the project Anthony vond he took it upon
himself to go through a lot of them he
probably went through 2/3 and I went
through one/ thir and he did it a couple
times where he got very very inated and
and just blasted through a bunch of them
and uh I think some of them might have
slipped through so if you're playing on
me you piece of [__] is that CU he
should have totally made that can he not
throw
anything I mean also this is you know
very beginning of the game so uh the
accuracies are pretty low on your Heroes
and like you know they got to have room
to grow they got room Room to Grow
anyway I'm going to try to explain this
gu got a lot of room to grow I just want
I just want to see what he says when he
kills
him track Point eat oh he eat what does
that mean SI I have no idea I there
could be like like gang slogans like
weird RAC the C say that's what CS say
track Point eat that's every time they
shoot someone what it could be like
different languages like just weird oh
and it's really funny actually like I
when they first started coming in I was
like I was very frustrated because I was
like oh man I was like why would
somebody give us all this money and then
like they're almost puroll trolling us
you know we have this other category
this nonic category was cool put it in
there now it's like really endearing
because I feel like they're just like
kind of my heroes are like kind of a
bunch of weirdos they say weird things
when they kill people and I'm like all
right it's like a weird meta game as
well it's um also there's like there's
over 2,000 of them in the game so on any
playthrough you're probably going to get
um I don't know maybe 20 25 total so
you're going to every time you play the
game you're going to see like new names
and new things and it's going to be
great he got there that time did okay so
yeah fifth time sorry pitch yeah I'll
eventually get there it'll be great I'm
excited so so you as a player you're
this Immortal ruler and you've been
summoned to help this uh to help this
nation sort of like see themselves
through this this war that's going to
last like 300 years and they they're
kind of under attack they're being
invaded by this thing called the Cadence
and nobody really understands it when we
get back to the map
maybe if we get back to the map uh after
this like it'll make a little bit more
sense we'll get back to the map the
whole nation is being surrounded by kind
of like this weird muck this weird sort
of miasma that's like kind of kind of
choking it from the from the outside in
it's called the Cadence uh and every
roughly like 10 years it it makes these
kind of like humanoid creatures and
sends them into attack uh they're called
pawns and they will like spread
corruption uh throughout the nation and
like you have to send in Your Heroes to
stop them so the real twist is that so
so here like this is pretty familar to
anybody that's played a game like XCOM
or Fire Emblem Final Fantasy Tactics
these are all games that like we really
love that we're super inspired by and
stuff but um this is pretty familiar
right it's like you're just like
controlling uh your characters from top
down perspective and you're and you're
fighting these enemies and stuff uh on
the strategy side though um because the
battles take place like roughly 10 years
apart um you're going to kind of make
your decisions like what technology
you're going to research um and you know
some other decisions like what what
buildings you're going to build things
like that but
in between the fights like when the
timeline's running all of your
characters are aging all your heroes are
aging just kind of naturally along with
the timeline then eventually they're
going to pass away so one of the biggest
um the most important decisions you have
to make is which characters are you
going to marry together you have to
retire retire them from combat and put
them into this special building called a
keep and there they will um you know try
right word they'll be trying um and then
hopefully they have kids and then
they'll they'll train those kids and
when the kids uh they they age as well
and when they become 15 they'll be
transferred to the capital and then you
can send them out on missions so it's
not straight up like Rogue Legacy style
this is the next Generation like your
characters are getting older right it's
very very uh we try to make it like as
simulation feeling as possible just
because that makes the game like a
little bit more Dynamic a little bit
more emerging and stuff is there a sex
mini game hidden in the code that
there's not I maybe put in there it's
not too late it's still in Early Access
at I'll just call up David jaffy and be
like if you're going to put something in
that I suggest it's going to be the
smoothies it's not going to be the sex
mini game all right that trait it'll
just get rid of textures on the face we
could probably do that that'll probably
lower the uh the cost a little bit po c
a little bit yeah just it's super simple
to have a very smooth head on C squares
you can just move twice if you like
unless you're I know but I'm he's a
hunter so I would like to try to get a
shot at this guy but he's pretty far
away I don't know do it going to
let I've seen her wipe on XCOM a bunch
play the long game the line of oh yeah
so yeah you got this um the white area
is where I'm allowed to go on my second
turn I had an orange area before if I
move within the orange area I get to
move again or attack if I move within
the white area I'm donez so I've already
moved once now I get to move twice so
I'm going to move again to get closer um
unfortunately this guy's about dead so
hopefully he doesn't get attacked or
he's going to die that's kind of my bad
seed
oh [__] okay he's fine that's brist
right we need to we need him to pull
really like him to breed if tedin can do
one I'm not a fan that would be great
Teddy's a real piece of [__] also I love
the so the um the symbols the for the
the editor like on their Flags like they
were just like a bunch of uh basic
shapes and and kind of like animal signs
and things like that and people combined
them had like a simple layering system
people combined them in some really
weird ways that was not expect you know
what nobody did there was we asked
specifically all right please no one
make a penis yeah we will have to reject
it and not a single person tried tried
to slip one in wow I was really shocked
actually so to speak uh yeah I not that
sh kill that thing well I have a problem
what's your problem well three of my
guys are disoriented and they're all
about to die yeah they got so the um I
got I don't you saw that blue enemy the
laps so so all of the all the pawns that
you fight they're all kind of loosely
based on uh the long-term effects of
time okay cuz that's really like the
enemy in the game like the Cadence kind
of repres always represents time it
represents uh like entropy the fact that
like you know heat death you can
philosophical on here brother I you know
I can people would not maybe expect it
from me given the shenanigans I do on
the internet but um but yeah I like to
think about stuff like entropy sometimes
kind of a downer is this game like
evocative of your place in time at the
moment you know actually TR to feel a
bit old and yeah you know I think that I
mean yeah like you said you kind of said
that like as a joke but it's like it's
like actually true like I got married
yeah married during this thing thanks
getting real going to have some
smoothies thinking about some smoothies
pretty excited I will not call them
smoothies though when uh or if uh we end
up having kids I don't think I'll call
them smoothies um what I've trade marked
so you're oh Mary here's an awesome Pro
tip yeah so what happened there so click
your other Hunter brosus I used brus was
that him right here brus so as you're
mousing around to your next destination
yeah uh watch the flag for the enemy and
you you get this eyeball that says like
if you are to move to this new location
you'll have line of sight to that
character oh I see the little eyeb
little eyeball turn it on we can make
that a little Where Have You Been never
leave I'm just you know what I'm taking
up residence in this C that's it look at
that that makes so much more sense it's
good we put that in there for you so so
this laps it represents um memory loss
it's kind of like our Alzheimer
J um so every time it hits uh one of
your Heroes they'll lose some of their
combat experience they actually Del a
little bit oh man um it's like dementia
yeah that's that's terrify kind of awful
right yeah so all of them and then these
seeds uh they represent um kind of like
unchecked growth so they have like a um
they have like a life leech and then
they can actually later in the game they
can all kind of get together and form
like a sort of D version of of them
called the cradle and then the Cradle
can spit out more seeds and it can kind
of get out of hand um oh that that one
sucks so bad because not only does he
shoot out enemies out of his butt but he
also shoots out I mean I guess if that
you get hit by the enemy it does like 16
damage if it just hits you that's a game
Ender right there that kill it's so it's
brutal and it's it's brutal in the sense
where this game is definitely for the
kind of person that is
thinking ahead it's so I get that exact
feeling of XCOM which is like you think
you got it and then you lose someone
that you really liked and it's your
fault for not thinking about it you
really have to be planning ahead um
you'll notice right now I had more stuff
to do I chose to not go and end my turn
because it would I'd be less likely to
get attacked which I really can't afford
to get attack right now so I'm being
super cautious and you get rewarded for
that by typically not dying although I
die have this also you've got an
alchemist down there the guy with 4 HP
walk him up and you can kill both of
them one bomb you got this honestly I
like it his odds hor bummer oh his odds
have been poor he's got this one though
did you say horse bummer Horus horse
bummer horse horse bummer I think that
one slipped through boom all right so
there's one and then this
this don't three exclamation points
don't yeah like I I mean yeah you st
that one just
really 55% don't miss nice
see
Point yeah oh okay other other cool
things about the video game so all the
heroes uh all the heroes have like a
genetic code okay so um you can see it
like oh he's going to die that was kind
of nice he just kind of ran right into
your right into brus waiting open arms
that was really convenient smash him oh
no you can save him though you got other
based on his performance you think he
should die I want him to die you want
him out he's got to go g vote him off
the island angry in the worst way
possible no more jumbalaya he's really
disappointed so yeah so all the all the
heroes have a genetic code which is sort
of hidden from you but it'll tell you
the traits that kind of manifest um and
it's all based off of like uh sort of
high school biology stuff like punet
squares got you um learn your punet
squares kids make those two have babies
and they'll Miss forever
oh no there's one more oh no oh
no only
50% crap oh so we'll take we'll take a
look at that in a minute so the The
Alchemist throws bombs but yeah for sure
you can just have him run up and and
attack with his claw oh really it's
actually pretty good yeah it's not bad
oh you [__] everyone's
dying this is on you Nicholas chicky
hind this Nicholas chicky hindes is a
cjack which is the class that we have in
the game um so they fight with like this
uh big kind of like medieval style
battery Ram but if we look at this guy
he's slow slow is really bummer it's cuz
he's so drunk moving drunk right now his
friends are going to die yeah I don't
know he get save him yeah we'll see what
we'll see what that uh what who that
seed attacks how am I supposed to sa
Humanity I got a bunch
of working for me I like the name
bro you're probably okay here goes oh no
oh
grus this is my nightmare oh my
God it's probably because three of my
shots
missed track Point track point8 track
point eight this might be the Last Enemy
on the map too why don't you have this
cjack come in and finish it off I like
it Jack Attack do it chicky hindes boom
that was that was the chicky hindes that
for the chicks chick for the chicks all
right I'm really sad I couldn't say BR
okay so then when your characters level
up here you can you can actually spend
their points um we have like uh we have
a talent tree for each of the three
classes in the game and like unlock
stuff yeah at level two you just kind of
like yeah you're just sort of forced to
take that one to kind of like learn how
it works also Jerry rumkin that's
Teddy's
brother just just leveled up um okay so
this is the uh Jerry was
always uh so this right here is the the
Strategic map like this is the nation
and you can see on the outside um that's
the Cadence that's kind of like
corrupting the nation from the outside
in you see those three diamonds on each
region those are um uh the corruption
strike so three strikes and uh a region
will like blow up and kind of sink into
the into the ocean into the messy ocean
that's what we call it that's does it
become a situation where you're trying
to save all of them but inevitably XCOM
style China pulls out its funding and
you need to you're going to it's so much
more brutal than that though because it
will just be destroyed so if you had a
building there like if you your favorite
family was like in that building that's
in that region and it gets too corrupted
it will just be destroyed and like fall
into the ocean always attack two points
in the map at the same time so at least
two at least
two okay so here so here in the uh in
the keep this is where you're actually
like making your marriage decisions and
deciding like who will be um who will
retire you can technically marry two can
you get two dudes you can actually yeah
you can absolutely marry two dudes or
two ladies together and uh we have an
adoption system so you can adopt into it
and it's cool because the when you adopt
the kids will uh not have the same
genetics right they have randomized
genetics so if you have two characters
that are like high level but their
genetics are kind of poor you could put
them in a same-sex relationship and then
like so the genetics bones but maybe
some of the traits there are if you see
this here like scroll up a little bit so
I can read that so this is uh Doki Bo
champ uh I think that's PR foring weird
enough be is it really yeah yeah so you
can see their uh you can see their
traits so the longevity infertile so you
probably don't want to retire the
infertile one and bare strength um
increasing their strength but then they
also have a personality so this Hero has
a stwart personality which means they
like they have more armor um that rubs
off on the kids that can rub off on the
kids as well and there's tricky ones too
there's ones that um like really good at
snowboarding yeah that's totally that's
totally in there Shredder we just call
that one Shredder yeah Shred the Nar
Shred the Nar Nar you can't see look
shred Cannon so that's uh bro's brother
I assume that shred is a man's name
shred some of them are tricky in terms
of technique because there's ones where
it'll say that the um percentage of your
chance to hit is actually higher than
what it really is that's so sneaky we
have an optimistic pessimistic
personality and it it will just lie to
you on the uh on the actual ridiculous
and it makes it so difficult on a game
that like
Statics and it's higher than it should
be anyway I like this guy he's brainy
he's longevity except he's a reer so he
might be drunk sometimes but that's F
that's like most dads so that's
Colby so now this is like this is like
selecting um a a marriage partner for uh
Colby oh I like
felinity one thing I would like to point
out is that you can totally what was
that I can't even tell if that's one
yours enough felinity mcir ball that
sounds like a real one who else we got
keep cing she's a great all right Samir
anoir shred Cannon shred Cannon sounds
like a porn name I'm looking for the
ladies um the ladies so the ladies these
are infertile infertile infer the ladies
will be sorted to the top all the ladies
iner I swear it's random these two have
a high chance for children um let's see
strong willed Nimble and King maker
that's good um so really we have a king
maker and queen maker we might rename
those cuz I feel like they're a little a
little deceiving but um that will
actually with King maker you'll have a
chance of having more Sons than
daughters and with Queen maker more
daughters than sons and that can
actually sort of sometimes paint you
into a corner where like you kind of
want to have like uh you want to have a
sex balance yes you know what I'm
talking you know what I'm talking about
I'm talking about a sex balance right I
don't know what that mean I'm
uncomfortable but yeah so um uh
increased intelligence Max HP movement
range so this is interesting like the
increased intelligence intelligence is
really good for Alchemists because that
actually makes their uh those flat those
those kind of grenades I got stupid
Alchemist because they missed a lot CR
guys weren't that great either but but
she is slow and then so so you have to
worry about the kids getting both the um
the genetic traits and the personality
traits and cuz they're going to mix
together like like I was talking about
high school biology style and so you
know sometimes you'll get somebody that
gets the worst of both Sometimes the
best of both usually a mix of both um I
was the
to were you really that's hard to
believe they wanted to take him out back
but your aunt saved you I think she put
me in that bag and threw me in the lake
I think she was trying to say what was
that awesome Irish name that you said
before the show started oh sersa sersa s
s o yourt s a o i r s e it's Irish for
freedom I saw it in the trailer for
massive CH she's a really yeah she's a
really do it got it some things I'm not
seeing which are really important to pay
attention to are things like um heart
disease and um diabetes diabetes we do
not have diabetes in the game did see we
should maybe put that in there put the
diabetes in just yeah it just Mak not
move at all McDonald's tray we we drove
bcon did you see that I saw it and I was
like this is actually really good that
they're yeah this so that's the name
again this is house bummer it's called
Bastion of the unfunny all that is not
funny is UN funny so yeah uh
thematically inappropriate thanks
backers that's all I can do so great so
cool so so one of the other major things
that you're going to do is down at the
capital which is the building in the
center is um yeah you can totally just
hit space bar and that that will skip
this so um this is where the the actual
massive chalice lives you know that's
what the game's called so we decided we
had our name first before everything so
we just decided to you know throw it in
there just it's an actual mess CH did
you have to redcon into uh no cuz we
actually like like the game was not
really designed like we actually really
just had the name before we had the
whole design of the game and I always
wanted to have this advisor character
that would like kind of it it's
basically it started out as as just it's
medieval clippy that's all it is it's
just like I see you're writing you're I
see you're trying to defend a nation for
300 years from a weird monster manace
thing uh and it would like help you out
and stuff and we talked about like what
it could be and there were some really
hilariously terrible ideas that myself
and the team came up with but uh
eventually we decided it's like yeah we
should just have it be the Chalice and
have it be cool uh because that was like
our logo and hey that's what were some
of the bad ideas that you threw out
there was uh there's this I think it's
Irish folk is it Irish folklore uh
there's this trout that is it's a
sensient trout do you know this the TR
of your people and there's like walnuts
that fall into the um into the pool and
the trout nibbles on them I think you're
talking about the salmon of knowledge
the salmon of knowledge that's it so we
were like maybe it should be a fish
that's in the chalice and you look over
the edge that's what you guys worship
right and you see the salmon of
knowledge it would be a RI it would be a
riff it would be a riff on the salmon of
knowledge all right I'm not going to
directly rip off the it's so it be it'd
be a fish swimming around in there and
you would like throw in some you know
walnuts of knowledge or whatever they
maybe they'd be peanuts peanuts going
back to your
childhood and then it would like come up
and it would like talk to you be like
hey Danny yeah I'm the S knowledge yeah
let me Dr some hot knowledge on you on
careful of heart disease and diabetes
right you be like oh thanks a while
somebody reminds me of a part of my
culture and it makes me feel like I grew
up inside of hobbiton like it's like
when I was growing up it was of
knowledge that's what Stam of knowledge
is it's in a giant tree and there's a
door with a little you know there's a
round door with a knob on it you open it
up you go in there and there it is got
that ring on his flipper flipper s don't
have flippers all right Brad Mir thank
you so much for coming on showing us
Master Char thanks for having me when
tell people when they can get and where
oh you can you can go by the game right
now and you can you know see play this
video game it's on PC and Mac PC Mac
Linux right now uh the Linux L you know
early access we're working on l a little
bit but um yeah it's been it's been
Super Rad to work on it and we uh yeah
we did we talk about the kickstarter
thing we kickstarted it last year and uh
I just want to say thanks again I don't
know what camera to look in where it's
at the this one we took the B this one
this one look at this one there you go
over there hi yeah
um just want to say thanks again to
everybody who lik back the video game
because it's been really sweet to work
on it and uh I hope you like it sweet
and thanks for coming on pleasure as
always thank you so much you can run
down the street back to the double F
I've worn this shirt especially because
every time Tim's been on the show I've
worn this shirt I have a lot of work
today why don't you stay here and just
give you some more tips write down all
the [__] that you know that I don't you
want to go to Halo you want to good at
Halo yeah I'm good at Halo okay give
we'll do a five minute tip break for
Chris Waters we'll be back in a minute
uh we're going to play some hot Halo
Assassin's Creed unities coming up as
well H but first of all here is a
trailer speaking of the salmon of
knowledge for everyone's favorite
Assassin's Creed hero the Irish Patrick
shade cormic shalele migil Rees
Assassin's Creed
Rogue I swore to uphold the tenants of
the
Creed to Never Compromise the Assassin
Brotherhood to stay my blade from the
Flesh of the
innocent I was a damned
fool do you swear to uphold the
principles of our order and all that for
which we stand and to do so from now
until death whatever the cost I do
you are now a
Templar I had such hopes for you
shay
attack
you will die as a traitor who are you to
decide what city first next fight arsh
you betrayed the Brotherhood AES and me
I will not let you destroy everything we
have
built this mad grab for
power it ends
now Heidi Heidi Heidi hi who BL
Assassin's Creed Rogue wa
the salmon of
knowledge there that'd be fantastic yeah
hey Chris hi Danny do you remember when
you were on a show last week and you
couldn't talk anything about this and it
was really frustrating I had just come
from an event that last week and it was
Robin I we're just there I was there too
it was playing halo the Master Chief
Collection multiplayer and Halo 5
Guardians beta multiplayer oh yeah lots
of Hal are you the guys who leaked all
that stuff on Halo 5 no we are
responsible professional who do job good
you got a little something brown on your
nose yes it's responsibility stain cuz
that's this that's filth that's
absolutely filth but it's today halo the
Master Chef collection is finally out
sorry I've been calling [__] like
seven years been calling thanks for
calling me out there John Halo John
we're about to play some hot John Halo
how's the multiplayer going we hoping
we're going to play some Halo uh so you
can see we're like hung up on the fine
game in the multiplayer playlist so uh
matchmaking having some problems on
launch day 343 Industries has posted
about it oh there's some peeps we got
some peeps uh they've posted about it
they've like made some updates and
whatnot so they're hopefully it's
getting better slowly but this is kind
of why we were uh we the review embargo
lifted last Thursday Friday like
midnight and we posted a review in
progress and this is kind of why cuz
with multiplayer being such a big
component of this and with like the
sheer scope of all the multiplayer stuff
they're trying to do in it being like
really ambitious like yeah they've got a
great track record for online
functionality but like just a lot of
maps a lot of stuff I can remember the
last time a Halo game had a troubl I'm
crazy I thought three four ODS they all
kind of had decent launches maybe one
did all no all those like single games
worth of multiplayer but I mean uh this
is you know we're jumping into the
trying to get into the Halo 2
Anniversary playlist uh and then there's
just like a bunch of of other playlists
like Halo 3 four what do you want to
play what do we want to
play one bomb assault or team Slayer
Slayer start off Slayer Slayer so how
does the multiplayer stuff cycle through
so it's based on what playlist you
choose so I chose uh Halo team Halo 2
Anniversary so they'll all be team
matches and they'll all be the
remastered maps from Halo 2 so can you
take off like can you say just whatever
and it'll like roll you into a Halo
three game and then into Halo one you
can choose the Halo 3
playlist that's making lists if you want
to do a custom
game the world's your oyster whatever
you want is there isn't a playlist yet
that's called whatever oh yeah they're
they're going to have that later there
are some that like there are some that
like mix them up and hot between games
which is really weird uh from playing
two hours of that at the event it's
really really disorient yeah you said
that they were like playing Halo 3 and
then they'd go okay we're playing Halo 1
Maps now and then that's a bit jar
double
jumping sprinting sprinting sorry yeah I
mean I'm pretty sure you can set your
your controller layout for all the games
yeah that's a really neat feature
actually you set your preference and
like when you're choosing it it can be
just for this game or for all games in
the collection and unfortunately I mean
I didn't do that when we uh got to play
it which was really frustrating like you
know that's an interchanged melee with b
and bumper and it would just really mess
with your head when you're going from
different games but yeah so you can like
have the same controller style which is
awesome but when it still comes down to
it they they are different games and
they are they do have different ways of
playing them like Halo 1 to you know
Halo 4 is those are completely different
games of like how you play so it must
yeah I guess it's like going back and
playing like Call of Duty ghost now
after playing Advanced Warfare for a
couple of weeks couple and Chris like
when we watched out of the event Chris
even had like a really funny way of
putting it which was like it wasn't just
like these different games it was like
man let me flashback to like where I was
personally when I play these games like
was I in my garage at you know age 15
screaming the other room you grew up in
a garage well a little shed in the back
uh called it a garage to just like Glam
it up a little bit so you've played all
the um have you played all the campaigns
that are available I have played parts
of all the campaigns I did not play each
one individually through to completion
so it's one anniversary edition two
anniversary edition which is a new one
three is just like a straight up porch
right or like as close to and then four
is I guess just four the same but three
what's the difference with three is that
it has 60 frames per second now oh yeah
does two as well
yeah what do you think and two got the
cut scenes completely redone cut scenes
are snip gorgeous yeah they are pretty
awesome yeah we could take a look at one
of those uh a little later on first why
don't you try killing a few people yeah
try murder a dude I will try but I'm
taking questions as well flashing back
to I just moved to California oh get
come here okay that guy was pretty dumb
was just really poor Battlefield
awareness but yeah it's like the way the
radar works the way the Health Works the
way each weapon works like the SMG uh
you know here versus the SMG in Halo the
other one uh three like nope that's a
grenade uh you know Needler tracking
stuff like all this stuff really is
uh really takes some adjustment yeah and
like you know Halo one you actually did
have he you know you had health finish
him up thank you had a shield but you
had health you could pick up medkits
that was something you would looked at
yeah if you got you know messed up you
would try to get a health kit all right
so this game has like four different
versions of Halo multiplayer you guys
have been playing it since you were you
know we Lads like when you're playing
this what is the best one because you
must be like propagating towards one of
them at this stage
yeah I would say uh so actually the
first one anniversary is like feels just
real archaic and it's actually the first
time you've been able to play it again
cuz uh when it came out it had uh the
multiplayer worked on the Halo 4 engine
oh you're right yeah so this is the
first one uh and that's just real slow
it's really uh like the way the pistol
the pistol is so so strong and so deadly
so floaty like I just yeah I was not a
huge fan
um hello I see you idiot uh so then uh
Halo 2 like we're watching it now it
looks really good there's not like that
kind of barrier to it but you know I
think Halo 3 is my favorite honestly
well Halo 4 is is really great but like
in terms of like what do I want to play
for like good Nostalgia fun times it's
going to be uh Halo 3 is it because it's
also kind of the most modern of them
well Halo 4 is most modern of them it
certainly plays more modern than Halo 2
yeah uh but it also in terms of like
controller kind feel like it you know
what it took me back to how it really
felt like like that game was just he's
one shot that was it was like the first
HD Halo it came in 2007 and it was just
oh God that God it's terrifying to think
the Halo 3 came out 7 years ago yep
that's absolutely insane get it nice
double was like one of the most fully
formed multiplayer games it was in made
the multi the whole multiplayer Suite
plus Forge yeah right wait for is Forge
in this as well yes there are three
versions of Forge or actually maybe one
version but you can do it in three games
cuz it's in anniversary and it's in or
Halo 2 Anniversary Halo 3 and
Halo but not Halo Combat Evolved
Anniversary um but yeah it's it's a lot
it's a lot of Halo and it's really
interesting to think about like what is
like putting it together this putting
this much Halo together getting totally
grenaded and Covenant carbin rob you
made a bunch of features about sort of
um in the lead up to this about like
your past with Halo you've played a
Absol magic ton of this what's your
favorite so if I were to say my favorite
it would be one it would be one now I
mean there's two reasons why it's one
one being that like that was all we did
so much land in my garage where I lived
all my life but um we played just we
didn't you know we didn't sleep we
played all the time it was really
intense and what we what I really wanted
to play is like original blood gch CTF
yeah and reasons being like it was so
simple you didn't have all these
powerups other than overshield and cloak
you just had more powerups than you did
in Halo 2 yeah yeah and that was it but
like you just you you just everyone
start off in the same playing ground and
it made for such intense CTF match but
like even now like is that just
Nostalgia saying that was the best time
you played like if you were to choose
out of all these in this version that's
what I mean I what are you playing
tonight like oh I mean I'd be playing
Halo 1 I I got I got to see if it's
still the same and you know what I'm
trying to say is like CTF was just so
strategic base where like you didn't
have all these other elements it was
just simply like gang a warhog picking
up your buddy across the map and
communicating that way knowing where the
weapon spawn is like just you you I know
I played these all to like a kind of
saturation where I still have this
muscle memory of like where stuff is oh
God this good for team I mean that's
what I'm saying it's like Nostalgia
based is how I feel that's why I I mean
what was my favorite it would still be
one but I'm just kind of playing off
like a nostalgic feel like I want I want
to try that again uh got a couple of
questions coming in Lando plumy in
twitch chats asking is the Master Chief
Collection a good enough reason to buy
an xbone to buy an xbone man that's a
tough sell cuz that's like what 350
bucks uh plus the master chief cost uh
no is this a nice distraction or is this
cuz we're in the middle of silly season
when it comes to releases like is this
going to be end more than just something
you'll play for a week
or get it sorry I'm in a situation it's
bad I mean I'm going to play it I'm
going to play I'm playing it for two
reasons you know a campaign like going
through all that again I love the story
of Halo so much I want to experience
that again all in one sitting you know
really not all at once sounds like
absolute worst that's no but like
playing it all again obviously not one
sitting yeah but like do you honestly
think you're going to do that this month
like is this a Chris what do you think I
think for me the value of owning the
Master Chief Collection is the same
value that you have when you're like you
bought a 360 you moved your Xbox out
from under your TV but you kept it
around and you kept your Halo copy
because you're like yeah I might want to
come back and play this it's having all
of these games from like different
periods of I mean for me personal
history but you know of gaming history
you can fire it up you can hop around
you can play it like you know whenever
you like for a little bit oh nuts you
can totally get owned by that guy you
didn't see uh it's that kind of thing
it's that like it's why I keep a game on
the Shelf it's CU I value it and I know
that I can go back to it and have a good
time like I can go back and do I can you
know set up a garage in my apartment and
like just put a bunch of empty paint
buckets in the corner roll out like a
sad cot like Rob had make some of those
little dummies with wigs on yeah talk to
them you know you can like have that
land party atmosphere you can do the
like legendary twers Co-op which is like
such a fun uh new yeah like that's what
I'm saying like that's what I'm going to
be doing too I got a buddy and we'll
definitely be loading up some of that uh
would you would you do it if you hadn't
played a crap ton of Halo like I'm I've
not played Halo 2 campaign ever so like
I'm kind of reasonably interested in it
but I remember getting Halo one
Championship Edition and then like never
our anniversary edition and then
actually not playing it much at all it
just seems like a really I wish this
game came out in like January or
something
like like Assassin's Creed and Far Cry
are out in the next couple of weeks like
that's why I'm saying like I'm not going
to be jumping into this this month you
know I'm not going to I might you know
like over winter break like you know go
back like play with my brother or
something like that you know it's the
kind of game that's it almost seems like
it it's not an immediate release it
doesn't demand to be played immediately
it does uh but it it has so much value
and so much there's so much goodness
there's so many so much good game here
uh that it's it's still really
interesting this is going to be an
interesting one for um yeah like I'm
coming from the perspective of somebody
who's not a massive Halo fan like I
think three is tremendous
and I really enjoyed one I'm still
bitter about the fact that it came out
on Xbox instead of PC first pissed me
off uh I think when it was Mac it was
going to be that strategy game though
right was going to be what I think it
was that strategy game back in it was
going to be a Mac game right well they
debuted at Mac world the first clip of
like Master Chief running outside and
like getting in a warthog and like d
like hopping in a banshee and that just
the like openness of that environment
that kind of vehicular Freedom was what
everyone was roaring about um I remember
PC Gamer had an exclusive on it with
like loads of screenshots and
information and then a month later it
came out that it was coming it was going
to be a console exclusive like you
[__] D there there were Legions of s
of cranky people who like yeah of course
cuz you get excited for the game and
like GNA GNA want to buy an Xbox for
that buddy I'm not sure if you're able
to talk about this but KY the gamer is
asking what do you guys think of the
Halo 5 beta footage are you are you able
to talk about the Halo 5 beta stuff yes
uh do you want to pick a playlist and uh
but oh we do Halo one yeah so like let's
just take a quick look actually this is
what the playlist uh currently looks
like in matchmaking for multiplayer yeah
this you know like we just that was the
one we were just in then you've got the
Halo championship series because they're
Reviving some competitive stuff around
Master Chief Collection you see Team
Slayer and big Team Battle do span like
big Team Battle SP all games so we could
go in there and just see where you end
up does it swap quickly between the two
of them uh it's just between the
different games like is there crazy load
times because it's jumping between no
not not in my experience but again uh I
haven't really played a ton of
matchmaking back to back to back to back
the event we played at was all custom
games and so that's another reason why
we we held off on the the final review
yeah uh but while we search for this
let's talk about Halo 5 Guardians cuz
it's a multiplayer beta and that the
story there is like all these movement
abilities that you are seeing in Destiny
and Titanfall and Call of Duty Advanced
Warfare this year totally in Guardians
double jumping no double jump can you
can you jump sideways Dash dashing left
and right and forward and back the the
double jump is basically replaced with
like you can now climb up oh really um
okay easier than you could before inhal
clamber clambering clamber like man c i
get it um and what else then you've got
a ground pound which if you're in the
air you activate it and you sort of like
you hover for a second and then Crossing
this reticle comes up and when it like
clicks white you go and like shoot down
and blast them up which is as opposed to
like Call of Duties is more advanced you
just or sorry quicker yeah you just is
an instant tap it and it goes down if
you hit directly it will kill but mostly
if you if it's a Miss then it's a it
Ducks The Shield yeah you can knock off
a shield or something like that cool but
it's it's more it's tougher you know
like you you're in midair you hover for
like a good two seconds and they can
shoot you while you're do oh yeah but
then you have to you know the guy could
change direction meanwhile you're you
know depending on where you are you're
you know taking the long long train so
he you know you could completely blow it
so what else levels so then you've got a
Sprint uh you can Sprint at all times um
infinitely but your Shield doesn't
recharge when you sprint oh wow so if
you're in a fight trying to run away
you're going to have to manage like do I
duck around the corner try to get a
little Shield back and if you stop him
does it start charging again immediately
okay uh I'm not sure if there's a delay
of like I stop now it's coming or
something like that uh but if you're
sprinting and you get ahead of steam
like basically if you sprint for more
than 2 seconds now now anytime you melee
you do a charge that will duck a shield
or if you hit someone from behind it's
an instant kill uh one there's a slide
yeah you can slide now Sprint and duck
you slide um and then the the hovering
aiming the hovering aiming is
interesting oh so like Destiny style
like you can if you're shooting isn't
one of the classes you can do like a
hover shoot yeah but I think can do that
in Destiny yeah yeah but Destiny is I'm
pretty sure you can kind of like travel
some distance and this one it's more of
a just stationary so you if you're you
know say I'm jumping off like a ledge
and I see you across the map I do get a
moment to like get a couple shots off
and then drop right oh okay so it's it's
all based on aiming so when I aim then I
hover yeah you a a s midair it will like
your jet jump Jets engage and you like
slowly descend but you're aim down
sights yeah so if you're like in pursuit
or like trying to get the drop on
someone I think it's good but if you're
like in a direct firefight it seems like
you're just hanging yourself up there
you're moving much slower you're
literally just a a Target hovering in
midair uh what about levels and weapons
and stuff like that we played three
levels one was blood gol one of them no
one was basically like midship uh the
sort of circular Covenant uh interior
from Halo 2 was that Halo 2 was the
first one uh there was that there was uh
Empire which is sort of like a
industrial small industrial facility
type thing and then there was one that
was Forge which was basically like a a
paintball map okay in TR Tron
like you wanted some arpeggio music on
there for we're going to keep talking
about this real quick I'm just going to
we've been waiting to get into a match
so we're going to maybe show you guys uh
like do you want to see a cut scene from
uh from Halo anniversary something some
video porn it's got some blur porn we'll
get something good looking yeah what's
another cool thing about this one is
like the HUD looks gorgeous and it's so
easy navigate all the different games
they did a really good job with the
organization of yeah everything yep so
all the missions are unlocked from the
beginning uh and then you start it up
and like you can you know resume quick
start or go Mission by Mission once you
choose a mission toop hop into uh what's
a good one to start with here yo do the
library the library library Metropolis I
believe this great tank one I've
actually seen that uh which is fun and
then so yeah like choose your difficulty
level choose your skull
there are skull are ton of these that
add in any new ones oh I don't know
that's a good question you have to
compare I guess did Halo 2 have skulls
no are all yeah those three I'm pretty
sure wow uh kind tell I mean I'm pretty
positive that's the case so we're going
to start uh just a mission here in Halo
to anniversary give you guys a look at
uh one of the sort of Ura cutscenes and
then shoot some things in a tank mhm but
back to Halo five guardians breakout
mode is another new mode they're
introducing and uh Fighters no it's
basically I mean name your game that
this has been in before but it's uh you
have one life per round and you don't
respawn and the first team to win five
rounds wins right so that's coming to
Halo for the first time uh I think I
first played that in like Socom or
something was I I mean I I didn't play
Counter-Strike back in the day too much
um but yeah so it's as intense as that
always is cuz it comes down to like oh
crap I'm the last man standing oh God
you know you die you really feel like
you're screwing your team over as
opposed to in a team death match you're
like ah I just died it's fine oh look at
this oh everyone shut up and so unlike
in the original aniversary one blew
right through us you can one with David
Cross switch old cut scene oh man not
looks like hot garbage now yep wait did
it did it reverse time there which one
is which so
do it again do it again Halo anniversary
oh my God yeah yeah so oh my God look at
this Jesus that guy has a face now he
has a face he smoo
before do it again do it again do it
again wow one like [__] Robot Chicken
version of the it's like
a
what's wrong with your
face looks good
though never got me
anything oh my is insane oh I know what
the ladies do it again do it again do it
again oh it's just a d end wow yeah can
you play the game then that way as well
yep back back
inted he's all inverted so in Halo in CE
Anniversary and also in two anniversary
you can just you just press the Box
button on the Xbox controller is that
what it's called boxes boxes well it's
lines and boxes D do the the Box boes
hit
it it doesn't look so bad look at a Sky
Box look at a Sky Box yeah so some of
them like yeah look up at the sign with
the ship in the background no don't look
turn to your right turn to your right
turn to your right oh my God that's your
shut your face did you invert the
horizontal controls
too there City back there now look the
other direction towards like the actual
Mission and the giant space thing wow
God I'm just a big dumb idiot
yes look at that this this does not look
as bad as the the cut scene absolutely
not those pre those uh cutcenes are you
know obviously pre-render whatever CGI
magic Studio can we have another look at
another cut scene can you just get out
of this and go to another level another
cut scene yeah like as much as the game
go to save and quit and then we'll pick
just pick another one the monster well
we showed the gravemind one on the uh
yeah we've seen that it's so on the live
oh really can you do it again can you do
it again do you remember the grave mind
yeah so the grave mine was like the was
like the really describe it to me it
like reach into your memory and describe
the grave mind for us it's like a it's
like a it was supposed to look like a
plant it didn't really look like a plant
it was like there was too much happening
I think it was like tentacles though
there were tentacles we should definely
face I don't think it had a face so
missions it just looks like a sock Halo
2 Anniversary missions yeah uh it's
right it talked I'm going to look it up
I'm going to look up with the grave mind
you don't have to Danny okay there's
literally a level called the grave mind
or just grave mind and we will choose it
and you will see hold on your butts uh
what grave mind looks like yeah uh so
Halo 2 campaign you never played it no
it was the one that split between Master
Chief and the Arbiter yes who's an elite
uh so that you got like this other story
line of like the internal conflict in
The Covenant between the elites the
uh yeah I was I did not really care
about the Halo story until four wasn't
two the one that was the multiplayer was
it was like it was the dawning of Xbox
Live multi but then the single player
stuff was kind of like a little bit
forgettable but it got a pass because
multiplayer was so incredible I think
that that's that's the way some people
view it some people really like that
that campaign and no yeah I didn't it
didn't strike me as amazing playing as
Arbiter was like all
right the r p like I want to be Solid
Snake want be he's got a sword man I
want to be John
Halo it his name is actually John 11
here we go here we go here we go uh all
right so this in this scene skip to the
crappy stuff skip to the crappy Stu show
the crappy stuff all so yeah boxes okay
so here's the real
scary are you scared let just look at
the let's get get a real closeup of old
timey grave mind all right so
you're you've seen nothing like this
before and now all of a sudden there's
like a plant talking at you but like is
it flood because it's green like what
are all these mouth flaps going on here
what the hell is happening I don't
believe
it and stop pressing it a million times
Rob just
once God what that's the Arbiter that's
the Master Chief and the grave mind and
hello oh my God is this thing look at
those teeth that's it's got teeth in its
teeth it's G it has so many teeth it's
got teeth on its lips and like if you
look like
so they inter it's like they interpreted
the layers of mouth as just like
different layers of gritty broken gnarly
go back again go back again okay want to
see the garbage version again there you
go switch back I think it's over after
this me go back oh man yeah look at that
it's got little teeth flaps inside of
its other
teeth uh so so they look so so good uh
and this Al I think this is one of the
reasons to like play through Halo 2
anniversaries to see these cut scenes at
least for me like it was I was like all
right I'll get i'll get back through
this but I mean so one at the start of
each level yes and and the end on the
end awesome uh and there's also a new uh
cut scene they put at the beginning that
involves agent lock from Halo 5
Guardians okay uh cuz they also put uh
terminals throughout the campaign so if
you're playing it on the new visuals
which you know is just a tap of the
button you can find these terminals
which are basically little screens you
interact with and then it takes you to
the Halo ch channel uh app and you watch
a little video or a still on your Xbox
yes it just switches automatically and
then it goes back in you know itself but
all that stuff lives on the Halo channel
app and uh how I keep saying app like
it's some weird dirty word it is cuz app
is a weird dirty word it's the worst on
the Xbox I've got one question here in
the chat it's from Les Moon vest
apparently yeah can you play with the
old graphics and multiplayer no you
can't switch can't switch Oh Oh you mean
for like Halo 1 or Halo 2 yeah yeah like
the original maps in Halo 2 yeah no no
no I mean like when you're playing can
you hit boxes Cann s
okay and you can't switch in Co-op
either well that's the one thing they
didn't put into this Master Chief
Collection which seems to have a billion
things happening in it oh my God there's
so many pretty good deal in fact this is
going to be really interesting for the
game of the year discussions because we
are having a new category this year I
believe which is all about remastered
reissues is that what we're going with
yeah so between this and sleeping dogs
and uh GTA 5 com
cons Metro yeah so like that's going to
be right now guess is this the new or
the old I think this is the new because
of the because like the ambient lighting
and fogs and stuff yep the lighting is
usually a good is usually a good way to
tell so Rob just yeah switch to the old
wow and so the lighting yeah is just way
it's it's much more flat I mean I'm no
lighting olist so my terminology is
pretty un profesh but like that's
correct lighting olist it is it's a lot
more basic obviously and now give us a
switch yeah look at the um the Needler
uh
crystals like they much pointier now
yeah they're nasty all those P there's
some more guys going to spawn sweet um
that'll probably do it for for halo the
Master Chef collection cool so yeah
we're going to have a review uh going up
later this week once I get a chance to
play a bunch of multiplayer cool uh see
how that shapes up and um sham me Halo 5
Guardians uh Rob and I did a lot more
in-depth sort of preview about so if
you're interested in what we're just if
you're interested in it you want to see
some of it in action hear a little bit
more out we've got a video on oh it's
there awesome all right thanks very much
folks Mark won's going to be on a minute
we're going to play some hot Assassin's
Creed Unity but first this is like the
fifth millionth trailer for Grand Theft
Auto 5 it's a new launch
trailer hey slick it's
me I'm a Darwin's brother all right so
prosper
enjoy the picture
everyone and some
struggle I thought you said you wern't
going to hit
me we had a deal we had
paperwork my daddy was not nice to me
life it's just one long
mystery Grand Theft Auto 5 coming
November 18th on PlayStation 4 and Xbox
one rated M for
Mature Grand Theft Auto 5 out again
November 18th that's next Tuesday I
believe is it today's the 11th oh my God
uh I'm going to do some sort of
elongated live stream for that because
that game is rad might do 12 hours of
first person or something something like
that you seen a first person mode yet
Mark Walton from Gamespot UK I haven't
but I am excited to see tra is pretty
dope yeah it it's amazing you can murder
people and pick up prostitutes now from
the perspective of someone's eyeballs
the feature is a wonderful place to be
you can break down one more barrier that
it's not you doing the terrible things
in Grand Theft Auto oh but you know
what's going to happen is that that PC
version is going to come out and
somebody's going to do Oculus Rift for
and punin and then first person punin
hav't even thought about that yes
imagine that non-fiction mod in GTA 4
remember that imagine that could you get
that chest vibration piece as well to
complete the immersion the whole thing
so like dudes just popping hot loads
onto your sorry into
your I don't know what game you've been
playing we're not here to talk about
yeah Mark Walton you're here to talk
about Assassin's Creed Unity yeah s out
of 10 review went up this morning it did
go up this morning it's okay yeah yeah
it's good but not great what are your
criticisms it seemed to be the story
stuff fell out Flash and the buggy as
well yeah I mean so the biggest thing
for me is the story basically you know
it's set in like revolutionary Paris
which is awesome like the backdrop you
know it's a great setting right you
think they'd be able to do some amazing
stuff with it right and there's some
cool looking stuff like you've got the
huge crowds and things like that but
there story is just like uh I'm this
dude and someone gets killed and you're
like okay like his dad gets killed at
the beginning it's the beginning of the
game number story spoilers the very
beginning of the game very beginning
it's the first thing that happens and
you're like okay I'm going to be an
assassin now aren't I because someone my
my dad's di this is how every Assassin's
Creed game starts and you're like I
don't I don't care anymore it's like cze
off's gun if you show a video game dad
that Dad has to die before the end right
yeah right so hopefully I havn't sported
but it does happen in like the first 2
minutes
um and yeah it's just the story is just
like this this sort of love story but I
don't really you don't really feel like
the characters are in love at all and
just none of that Paris backdrop is used
well at all and like you're saying bugs
yeah so it's got a bunch of technical
error I saw like the PC version uh
apparently it's been a bunch of folks
having problems with it uh you reviewed
it on Xbox one but you still had like
what like lockups and stuff yeah well it
still had issues I mean the PC version I
haven't played personally but I have
seen some of the footage and yeah that t
has been like the buggiest one out of
all of them the Xbox One from what I've
seen has been the smoothest really um
there are still issues there's like
poppin
issues severe Poppins with large crowds
especially the more people the NPCs when
you're swimming through them they'll
just kind of a hat will come out of
nowhere yeah exactly it's really weird
and there's like there's like bits where
like NPCs will just suddenly start
walking in midair you'll do it as well
like if you go over a jump there was one
point was like trying to jump from like
a post to another post and instead of
jumping he just went like that really
Weir and I wish I captured it but it was
just yeah it was great so it sounds
maybe a little bit like Assassin's Creed
1 how it was a little bit rough around
the edges and then by the next one they
kind of well it's new tech right I mean
you know this is a new engine that
they've been working on for like four
years or whatever and yeah 7 million
people have been involved in the
development 12,000 Studios yes that's
about right yeah I heard that in every
time zone yeah it's kind of nuts and
it's it's not ready like it needed
probably like another six months I
reckon it's one of those things right
it's like this is the Christmas game
yeah true it has to come out now is
Ubisoft Christmas game right if they
don't get this out along with Far Cry
right which does look a lot better than
this then uh you know they're kind of
screwed and they I guess with Watch Dogs
they already ran that sort of Gauntlet
with didn't they already learn from that
as well I mean it it wasn't ready
there's there's issues with it
everyone's noticing and talking about
now but it was it was delayed by 6
months like they did
they on this one well I I they could
have afforded to this is the cash C
right Assassin's Creed 900 P lock baby
yeah so let's hop on in let's see some
pois yeah so go the Eiffel Tower so this
is my dude uh as you can see I have the
master Assassin outfit because uh when
you get to the end obvious I love how
you instantly just ran straight into
someone get out the way
[__] double assassination and you hit
him
afterwards he's like he's dead but you
got got to make sure you know got to
make sure dou tap uh yeah so I mean let
me see if I can show you some of like
what Paris looks like because it's some
of like the best bits really like yeah
how good does it look like are the
crowds really impressive are the the SC
the scale of it let me take you
somewhere oh Jesus let me take so
there's e the FR that's a lot of things
let me take you to a place you didn't
open very many chests at all did
you well you know there's a lot of
chests to do like the annoying thing is
right with some of these chests is that
some of them are ones you can only
unlock by playing in the Assassin's
Creed companion app on your IP of oh go
I'm just like No And it's awful it's
really bad it's so boring I feel like
there's no better time to have a younger
sibling so that you can just just give
them the app and be like we're playing
it together you're helping me out Sonic
and Tails your
tail it's just we're playing it's so
yeah it's so annoying um so whoa let me
get yeah so this is like the
pantheon look at this look at all this
parrot can you make it zoom out do that
thing
cinematic do the Cinematic time yeah the
first time synchronized and I've
synchronized all of them so um where's
the jumpy down bit okay I when I was
watching stuff before it looked like
they didn't have oh god um sick piles
of freaking hay everywhere but do they
have big PES of py everywhere there's
one on the roof right there Lord knows
how it
that's the stupidest one I've ever seen
there's hay everywhere like I mean so
like the architecture in this is why
can't I get down you can down parkour a
lot in this game like that for instance
rtb yeah but it it is kind of
frustrating that it doesn't always do it
when you when you want it to oh really
um have you jumped to your death much at
all oh yeah really yeah I've jumped to
my death several times because it's
decided that I needed to jump to my
death clearly I wanted to just jump to
that other post um you can also jump
right into the site of people you were
trying to be sneaky and avoid without
wanting to do that and you can um jump
around windows like three times before
you actually jump through the window
that you wanted to jump through which
can be irritating on time missions uh
speaking of the missions how are they
one of the criticisms um the missions
are quite cool right so you can instead
of I need to kill this dude die die die
die die die he's got a great hat there
we go murderous hat finish
him so yeah so the big the key
difference with the missions this time
is that you're you're not limited to
like a set of options like you have to
go in and like poison someone's drink or
you have to like go in like a certain
entrance or whatever you can just it's
like a Sandbox it's like hit man like
okay I guess would be the the sort of
closest example to it so you can you can
just sort of choose what you want to do
and it's quite I like that it's one of
the best things about the game is like
the freedom that you have is there much
variety then in terms of that stuff H is
there much variety like in the levels or
is it always poison or stab them when
they go to the bathroom or well that's
what I mean like you know you basically
you when they're on the JN um so they
they sort of you get the options at the
beginning what happens is Arno does his
thing like he scans the area and then he
goes okay here are some options that you
might want to try like poisoning this
dude and then you can go no screw that
I'm just going to go and like kill
everyone in this huge Massac can you
just like like throw a grenade at the
dude yeah you have like these little
bombs actually so you can just sort of
go in there like throw a couple of these
bombs around and just like Slaughter
everyone they were like sweetest
Fascination bro everyone saw you and it
was
awesome are they just going to execute
those dudes in the middle of the street
yeah these are like um this France these
are these oh god there a lot I've
miscalculated
miscalculated mistake do you ever hear
the people sing singing the songs of
angry man uh unfortunately not there's
not a lot of singing you know uh despite
what L miserab award have you believed
uh revolution in France was not a happy
place actually the revolution for that L
Miz was set in came later in 18th
century really so you know that there
was a period of time where the whole
populace of France learned to sing very
well and then the citizens had another
Uprising this time with Incredible
soundtrack nerd a lot of people like
Assassin's Creed 4 Black Flag um is
there any stuff in that game that you
kind of Miss do they replace like for
instance they got that ship combat down
really well like that was a really cool
addition to the series is there any like
extra new stuff in here cuz they've been
real hit and missed like that Tower
Defense nonsense they had in Assassin's
Creed was a three was just yeah that was
nuts there's to be honest there's none
of that it's quite stripped back in the
way it works it wants you to just get on
with stealth basically and you know
that's nice and the combat in this is
really good um like I've just been
playing uh Rogue right it feels like
very old having played this
um it's just a shame that there's so
much of it that just doesn't quite work
in the way it should and it just feels
like I missed opportunity really like
after four years you're just like come
on guys like just give it a chance if
it's not ready it's not ready you're
going to take a hit but they did add
some cool stuff um like the part where
you can see where you where they last
Saw You Makes
Little Ubisoft we we put mechanics that
work in one game into every game they've
straight up put the Splinter Cell um
yeah it looks nice and it's helpful I'm
just looking forward to when they bring
elephants into Assassin's Creed oh did
you just SN that guy's neck like with
your wrist yeah that was ridiculous like
some DOL long run nonsense oh God do the
splits can do the splits so this guy's
chasing me out there you go there's a
silhouette that's the last place you saw
me look like you just dropped a ghost
yeah dropped a juice um so he's um he's
like going to be like looking 50 Creed
points that's amazing how many how many
cre points do I have to accumulate to
get their latest album to get tickets to
their to their to their latest show I
don't know uh you have to hack that by
doing
microtransactions the companion app yeah
I hate this future we living no like one
of the cool things is like um like the
customization and this is quite cool let
me see if I can there it is like the
gear load out you can like this is like
the master outfit but if you were to
pick like one of the regular outfits you
can you can sort of buy all these
different herds and stuff and they do
like they all have different effects
like that one gives you like way more
health and better stealth what's hack
upgrade about uh so you can you can log
in and buy uh certain things with real
world money yes you can yeah it won't
work on this version um but you can you
can go in and it contacts the ioft
servers and no yeah but it's not you
think I didn't say you think I said the
m word just casually oh my God I thought
you were joking micr transaction you
don't need to do that it's not know is
that for single player only or is that
no cuz your R looks like your rno in
Coop right it works cross them to be
honest you don't it's completely
pointless you don't need to do it like
it's unless you're totally desperate or
you just like suck oh but you know that
people do it cuz they wouldn't put it in
the video game otherwise there must be
like
.1% of people that do it use your left
bumper shoot him in the dome I don't
want to shoot this guy that's one of the
things always I hate about Assassin's
Creed games is shooting like I feel like
you know when you're like these guys
have no honor like I'm the goddamn sword
don't shoot me in the face okay don't
bring a sword to a gunfight yeah but
they just you know no you have a lot of
Honor but you're dead there's no honor
only you're in alive yeah right
obsessive gamer asks do you manage
assassins like in Brotherhood please no
uh no that stuff's not in here there's
none of that there's like none of that
stuff um let me see if I can find like a
cool Mission we can
do like an
assassination uh question mark yeah for
you a person who has been to actual
Paris o have you seen uh come across
sites in the game that you've recognized
and been like oh y yep that's what it
looked like it looks like a one to one
kind of it is one to one they claim it's
one to one anyway um no because this is
a very old version of Paris yeah but is
like the Latin quarter set of the par
see I haven't explored Paris as much as
all that um like I you know I remember
stuff like the Eiffel Tower and the AR
the tri and stuff like that and oddly
enough in this game do get to see like
the Eiffel Tower when it goes into one
of those weird like flashback travel
time travel Shard things of course yeah
yeah it's got those in like so that
there's like a World War II World War II
like I I know that Ubisoft have when
when they ask people about the time
settings that people want Assassin's
Creed to be in one of the most common is
World War II wow and it yeah it wouldn't
work right it's it's just silly they
just change it into Medal of Honor they
make it like the sabur like a real
stealthy is that SA thinking of velvet
assassin not sa oh yeah sabur is the
other like the farry version velvet
assassin sounds like prison lingo
there's one with the Statue of Liberty
in it as well yes which so that happens
as well yes wow before they shipped it
over wow idea so it's cool yeah you have
to climb to the top of the Statue of
Liberty and uh yeah try and sort of so
like where are the EI would be you got
to go to the old parts of Paris man
because I totally saw some stuff that I
recognized I mean like like I mean other
than like notredam is there like a how
do you do the map this one all right
there's a map but yeah so there's like
so the center Island I mean the map's
huge right um Eiffel Tower was so this
is the Lou and this is the yeah so
what's that Garden called again it' be
just across the river to the Southwest
yeah that guy like actually AR the will
be up here no cuz that that big building
down there where the like to the left of
the blue thing see the blue yeah go to
go further left what's that big building
that's like the a museum now uh that you
can that's like the armory museum so if
you go further to the left that's that's
where like further to the left of is
this the L here then I can't remember so
then that would be the Arctic Triumph
would have been up here but I guess it
just doesn't go up far far enough I
guess I mean the city is huge though
there's no momart or anything or P pigal
or anything of that is there no what
sorry M like up in the north you can't
get up that far no the only other thing
you can do is travel to Vera oh really
um which is like a smaller map it's
mostly um for like the Paris of Versa um
which is part of the story line yeah cuz
that's pretty far outside of Paris good
like you can do that if you want um but
this is so this is like a mission like
it's open-ended like I said it's given
so like you've got these like things
there um but I have to assassinate a
dude I am terrible at this that should
have been was well we don't have the we
don't have the sand up here as well
should have been was stealth now you
just got like a bunch of guys aiming
guns that you're dumb yeah oh and
there's a cover system so um you can you
can sort of like Crouch all the time now
just like left trigger which is
incredibly handy um and then if you keep
doing that they'll forget that you're
there in about 20 seconds yeah exactly
is it not totally weird that all of the
people in Paris speak with British
accents yes I hate it it is stupid from
your time in France people didn't speak
in British accents didn't speak English
in the queen's English it's so
Preposterous because they hate those
accents too it's like such a part of
part of fr is like the mannerisms the
way they speak and everything so it must
be so jarring to all these Cockney ass
parisians it's not just cocky right
there's like TOS youve got like Crush
guys there's like cockes there's guys
from the West country there Farmers yeah
is it like liverp in accents not liver
pudan but like Scottish I'm trying to
think about Scottish I don't think so
but it's it's like the vast majority of
like accents are like represented and
you're just like why why is this a thing
considering like and I'm just playing
Rogue right there's a french guy in that
he's got a damn French accent right
that's how it should be like I don't
understand like what the concern was
with like having that so um yeah why
can't I S that guy scrb says I turned
the dialogue to French because the
British accents were so weird that's
amazing yeah you can you can change it
but the default is like British
obviously um it's great and stick on
subtitles or something jump up on that
Legend yeah jump assass them I remember
U Vinnie when he played Assassin's Creed
I guess Brotherhood or something would
put on the Italian Voice work and then
the subtitles like that's actually which
is quite cool and it's neat you can do
that I just the default ones just
infuriated me I was just like I don't
understand um but there you go there's
some there's some like reason for it as
well they were saying like oh you're a
British dude in the animalist so it
translates all the people into but
didn't do that in Assassin's Creed too
did it how much animous nonsense is in
this none really well there's like a
tiny weeny bit at the beginning and
you're like oh you're in the Helix thing
like oh God
and then pretty much after that you get
one or two little cut scenes oddly
enough is the polar opposite in Rogue
Rogue is all about abstergo but you have
to walk around in abstergo oh God all
Black Flag yeah it's it first person
stuff again yeah it's first person stuff
like you walk around trying to find crap
in there and you're like okay so it's Lo
him Rob his Rob his corpse he's not dead
not
butt just looted his internal organs
oh man that's a really
nasty they are really vile there's the
one where you poke a hole in the middle
of their throat with your sword um it's
Ste uh you just kind of go up to them
and and put a little hole in their
throat and then they die silently do
that guy's already covered blood throat
hole Thro hole I thought you were going
to stab him in the junk that'll kill him
man will it he L he loves smoothies I
mean it would suck is that the guy
you're supposed to murder oh no but he's
dead now it looks like you just smacked
him in the ear you got the hidden blade
I feel the hidden blade things are a lot
more casual this time around you're just
like tap them on the shoulder like all
right good on you and they're
like it's one of the best things though
just like walking around the streets and
you're like just Cas you're like oh hey
hey how's it going see you later all
right
bye dead cool yeah snuffed out your life
uh I'm a casual murderer I'm the Casual
murdery Guy s y Shire in the Gamespot
chat asks is the customer feedback stuff
from Black Flag in here so at the end of
each Mission does it ask you to race the
missions at any stage no there's like a
you can do it well there's a sort of
thing at the beginning like that that
sort of alludes to that but no you don't
have to you don't have to but like the
missions do like I've been I played a
little bit this morning and it's like
you press you get the complete like this
mission was complete and you can like
replay and Contin or really yeah you
what is this how soon are we from like
having Gam
the at the end and they them
all and we're all out of jobs that' be
pretty good yeah oh no sign
well I guess the guys are preparing for
another stream that's happening after
this so pulling [__] out sure sure let's
just finish the show fine we weren
enjoying playing Assassin's Creed we
don't care about France you reached our
limit on France that's itam France
France do one when's the Rogue soon as I
get it done like do I am I've been
playing it today you're doing that
you're doing the Grand Theft Auto 51 as
well 5 yeah busy times man yeah video
games are right video GES Big Time video
games let's go play and review some more
video games then uh we're going to
actually play Assassin's Creed co-op in
a little bit uh at 400 p.m. which is an
amount of time from now 30es an hour
half an hour we're going to be playing
four player co-op online me Kish Ty Rob
uh sweet G to have some Shenanigans cool
yeah so stick around for that one uh but
we're out of here on the lobby thanks
everyone for watching thanks to BR me
for coming along thanks to everyone in
production Josh dantay all those sweet
folks not yeah I was going to say thanks
to Tay but then he just
pullu video games shut it
down
oh